fortschritt im ukraine konflikt kiew und
separatisten tauschen gefangene aus
countdown in philippsburg in zwei tagen
wird das atomkraftwerk für immer
abgeschaltet
tödliche lawinen vier deutsche skifahrer
sterben in den alpen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg genannt und willkommen
zu einer kurzen sonntagsausgabe norbert
lehmann ist auch dabei für den sport ein
sogenannter vor mir
es gilt als weiterer kleiner
hoffnungsschimmer im blutigen ukraine
konflikt zum zweiten mal in diesem jahr
haben pro-russische separatisten und die
ukrainische regierung gefangene
ausgetauscht
seit fünf jahren wird in den
ostukrainischen provinzen donetsk und
lohans immer wieder gekämpft was der
gefangenenaustausch jetzt bedeutet zeigt
christian sind die nächsten drei macht
euch bereit ruft ein separatist den
ukrainischen gefangenen zu streng
bewacht beginnt am vormittag der
austausch zwischen der ukraine und den
pro-russischen kämpfern in der nähe der
frontlinie für 200 menschen endet heute
einen teils jahrelange gefangenschaft
die meisten glücklich aber manche auch
unversöhnlich
wir sind glücklich dass wir frei sind
nach vier jahren für einige und fünf
jahren für andere befreit von den
fesseln des ukrainischen nazis muss wir
sind inspiriert und bereit zu kämpfen
ich wurde zu zwölf jahren haft
verurteilt wegen landesverrats in der
sogenannten lohans k volksrepublik
ich hatte meine eltern besucht und
konnte die stadt leider nicht mehr
verlassen
der gefangenenaustausch war beim ukraine
gipfel anfang dezember in paris
vereinbart worden es war das erste mal
dass sich der ukrainische präsident sei
lenski und russlands präsident putin
persönlich trafen deutschland und
frankreich vermittelte
nun also der versprochene austausch 124
gefangenen durften in die separatisten
gebiete 76 wurden im gegenzug den
ukrainischen behörden übergeben unter
ihnen soldaten und mehrere zivilisten
dass dieser gefangenenaustausch jetzt
überhaupt funktioniert hat es erst mal
positiv zu sehen
ein weiterer schritt auf dem weg zu
einem möglichen frieden in der ost
ukraine bis ende des jahres soll
außerdem noch die waffenruhe an der
frontlinie eingehalten werden auch das
war in paris so besprochen worden
aber das wird ein schwieriges stück
arbeit denn die waffenruhe wird dort
jeden tag immer wieder verletzt
der weg zum frieden in der ost ukraine
ist also noch sehr bald im nächsten jahr
dann soll es weitere friedensgespräche
geben
verteidigungsministerin
kramp-karrenbauer will den kampf gegen
den terrorismus in der afrikanischen
sahelzone stärken
sie plädiert für ein robusteres mandat
für die bundeswehr in mali wie es etwas
frankreich schon hat in der region
entstehe eine drehscheibe für
terrorismus und menschenhandel sagte die
ministerin der frankfurter allgemeinen
sonntagszeitung
baden württembergs grüner
ministerpräsident kretschmann und kritik
an der spd und ihren beiden neuen
vorsitzenden
statt zu überlegen was das land braucht
frage die spd sich vor allem was die
partei braucht sagte kretschmann dem
tagesspiegel am sonntag
auch sprach er sich erneut gegen ein
rot-rot-grünes bündnis auf bundesebene
aus
anderswo werden atomkraftwerke gebaut in
deutschland werden sie nach und nach
abgeschaltet 7 sind hier noch in betrieb
drei davon bis 2021 nämlich brokdorf
grunde und gundremmingen drei weitere
emsland neckarwestheim und isar bis ende
2022 ein siebter der meiler in
philippsburg wird an silvester um 19 uhr
für immer abgeschaltet was viele dort
bewegt petra otto sie sind in feierlaune
die rund 200 atomkraftgegner nach
jahrzehntelangem kampf ist die
abschaltung von philippsburg ein
etappensieg baden ist atomkraftwerks
frei ein kleines länder kleine
geschichte aber ihm haben wir sechs
reaktoren und jetzt in sie stillgelegt
und der wird jetzt über morgen den geist
aufgeben
13 prozent des beiden württemberg stroms
fallen weg über nacht wenn dieser
reaktor nicht mehr läuft und dann
versorgungsengpässe
zwischenzeitlich wird wohl auch
atomstrom aus frankreich die lücke
schließen müssen deutscher wind und
solarstrom allein reichen zur zeit noch
nicht aus darüber hinaus natürlich auch
noch kraftwerke die dann einspringen
wenn der wind nicht weht und die sonne
nicht scheint und dass wir eine wesen
gaskraftwerke sein
da müssen auch neu gebaut werden aber
prinzip ist auf dauer wind und solar die
lösung die wir haben
und das sollte man schleunigst weiter
ausbauen für die atomstrom befürworter
auch sie demonstrierten heute in
philippsburg ist die abschaltung ein
fehler weil kernenergie fast co2 frei
sei also besonders klimafreundlich für
mich ist es ein sehr emotionaler moment
ich finde das ein absolut falschen
katastrophalen schritt den wir hier tun
wir nehmen aber durchaus wahr dass die
kernenergie langsam den weg zurück in
den öffentlichen diskurs findet und das
bewerten wir auf jeden fall sehr positiv
15 jahre wird der rückbau des kraftwerks
dauern
der atommüll wird hier in philippsburg
zwischengelagert ein endlager ist
bislang nicht gefunden
die familien vor nicht abseits sondern
mitten auf der skipiste als die lawine
sie mit riss eine mutter und zwei
siebenjährige mädchen haben das nicht
erlebt überlebt diese tragödie in
südtirol wirft viele fragen auf auch ob
der pistenbetreiber das risiko falsch
eingeschätzt hat thomas garcia mit
details strahlende sonne leuchten bei
schnee im schnalstal und etwas das alles
überschattet kinder kommen ums leben
eine mutter die deutschen unterwegs auf
skiern dann kommt eine lawine die pisten
waren okay es gab einen lawinenwarnung
aber diese katastrophe unvorstellbar
zumal die strecke nicht gesperrt war
hätte sie das sein müssen lukas rastner
untersucht das hat die lawinengefahr
ansteigen lassen
das schneebrett ein kilometerlanges
raster 500 meter hinab er kann aber auch
durch den wind so richtig schweren und
harten blöcken zusammengepresst sein
die genaue konsistenz der lawine ich
muss ich mir und morgen noch anschauen
südtirol das idol heute meldet es wieder
einen toten lawinenabgang aufbruch für
die bergwacht
die saison hat gerade erst begonnen in
vielen deutschen städten und in ganz
europa erinnern so genannte
stolpersteine an opfer der nazi diktatur
mitte der 90er hatte der künstler gunter
demnig die aktion gestartet
heute hatte in memmingen den 75
tausendsten stolperstein verlegt vor dem
früheren wohnhaus der jüdischen familie
rosenbaum die aus deutschland fliehen
musste ein weiteres zeichen gegen das
vergessen und jetzt zum sport norbert
und einem spektakulären transfer
fußball-bundesliga der bvb hat das
tauziehen um erling holland gewonnen
der norwegische jüngster von rb salzburg
wurde ja von einigen top vereinen
umworben holland bekommt einen vertrag
bis 2024 und reist schon kommenden
freitag mit dem dort gehen dann ins
trainingslager der ein meter 94 große
stürmer sorgte dieses jahr in der
champions league für furore in sechs
spielen erzielte er acht tore und von
einem top transfer zu einem topspiel in
der premier league dort trafen im
londoner stadtduell arsenal und chelsea
aufeinander
die gäste gewannen knapp mit 22 1
zweites spiel für mit keller täter als
arsenal trainer und wieder kein sieg
obwohl seine mannschaft mit özil in der
startelf furios beginn 13 minute der ex
dortmunder oper milliarden trifft nach
einer ecke zum 1 0 in der zweiten
halbzeit die ghanas dann zu passiv
chelsea dominiert und erzielt den
ausgleich schoss ihnen nutzt leno's
fehler zum 1 1 in den schlussminuten
leno wieder unglücklich der ehemalige
leverkusener von abraham getunnelt das
einst zu chelsea dreht das spiel und
festigt vorerst den vierten
tabellenplatz
micaela chiffren ist einfach nicht zu
stoppen
gestern der sieg der us-amerikanerin im
riesenslalom heute ihr triumph im slalom
beim letzten weltcup rennen des jahres
in lienz
sie rückt lindsay wollen in der ewigen
bestenliste immer näher
weltcupsieg nummer 64 nur noch 18
trennen sie vom rekord ihrer landsfrau
der slalom heute wieder eine
demonstration im ziel über sechs zehntel
vorsprung vor der slowakin petra nova
und michelle gisin aus der schweiz
die deutschen damen können ebenfalls in
feierlaune in die silvester
vorbereitungen gehen
lena dürr auf rang sechs und christina
ackermann 85 bescherten dem dsv einen
erfolgreichen jahresabschluss insgesamt
fünf deutsche fahrerinnen in den top 30
das was mir noch das wetter im osten und
nordosten zeitweise wolkig sonst scheint
nach nebelauflösung überwiegend die
sonne
die höchsttemperatur liegt zwischen -2
grad im dauernebel und +10 grad im
westen
das war es von uns um viertel vor zehn
begrüßt sie claus kleber im
heute-journal hier übernimmt ab morgen
petra gerster wir wünschen ihnen noch
einen schönen sonntagabend auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]